كلمه نسمعها نفهمها ونعيشها واقعا في
المكان
[موسيقى]
ولكن ماذا عن الانسان
العلاقه بين الجمال او الجاذبيه وبين
النفسيه موضوع شائقا تطرق لها العلم منذ
خمسنيات القرن الماضي واليوم خمس دراسات
على موظفين امريكيين والطلاب صينيين
الجذابون انانيون او على الاقل الذي لا
يعتقدون
ان ذا بول
[موسيقى]
وسار اتحدث اليوم من عاصمه من اشهر عواصم
الجمال عن ظاهره او متلازمه في علم النفس
وهي مبدا الجميل جيد يعني انك اذا شاهدت
شخصا جميلا ستكون اكثر ميلا للاعتقاد بان
صفاته الانسانيه جيده وانه صادقا ومحب
وطبعا لا علاقه للجمل بذلك الدراسات ايضا
حسنت ان جميلين يتمتعون بتمييز لصالحهم في
العمل من قبل المديرين وفي الدراسه من قبل
المدرسين وحتى في التحالفات المهنيه
والسياسيته والاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
وفي النهايه الجمال هبه ثمينه فهل تتحول
بالنسبه لصاحبها سببا للانانيه والاعتقاد
بانه يحق له ما لا
يحق لكن الجمال الجمال